the last of the pro-life Democrats
really got excised in the battle way
back over Obamacare in the Battle of
whether or not Obamacare would cover
abortion right so the last of those
pro-life Democrats have really been
shoved for the margins of the party I I
mean Biden's an interesting case in this
because obviously even 10 20 30 years
ago as a quote unquote Catholic he was
talking about this issue very very
differently still sometimes he you see
that because I don't know if because
he's just used to talking about it that
way or he literally slips in time it's
not clear for many of his other
statements right but sometimes you still
hear from Biden this like safe legal
rare language he condemns it from a
moral perspective it says well it's
between a woman and her doctor and the
state shouldn't get involved this is all
sort of old language from the Democratic
party that I think is very much out of
favor with party's activist class and
therefore with its politicians the
language now is very much to celebrate
abortion so yeah I think they are the
party of abortion